now you may recall in this exercise I
asked you to do all the sign ones ok now
that we know cause intent it's time to
open the door so let's have a look at
one beat really quickly tan theta equals
negative 3/4 ok now I've saved some time
right now 3/4 is not one of our nice
exact value angles ok so we're going to
get some not 30 or 45 or 60 it's gonna
be some read angle okay so let me walk
through how this is going to arrive at a
solution right I'm gonna go through this
same person's right but I will walk you
through nice and slow firstly to get my
face of danger like this one right 45 or
60 ok I'm going to use 10 inverse
because I've got tan here right but and
this is a critical thing with this some
with this technique put it down if
you've got a different color right to
get what we call the the base angle the
one where I'm like I just take the base
angle in the first quadrant or I go 180
take away the base angle or 180 plus the
base angle or 360 take away the base aim
to get that angle you weak nor the sign
okay I'm gonna write that down you
should too to get the face angle ignore
the sign okay so in other words what
you're gonna put into your calculator is
tan inverse lot of negative 3/4 but just
3/4 tan inverse of quarters okay now
just for the purposes of keeping this
nice and simple in fact I think it's
what they asked let's just do this
nearest degree don't worry about
decimals or or minutes or anything like
that we want to focus on the technique
rather than the size of the angle so 10
inverse does anyone already got it 36 37
37 we're approximating yeah 37 that's
fine so let's just take that as our base
integral now you look and you say hold
on a second I want 10
to be negative right tend to be negative
so when I look at all nations to central
in which of the quadrants out of the
fourth where is 10 negative 2 it's going
to be negative over here right because
sine is positive so Tammany negative and
you'll be doing it over here you see
that because Cosme positive I will point
out to all of you if you just go to your
packet yeah and you go what I won't go
shift setup that's on the top row of
your calculator shift set up and you can
see there's a whole bunch of different
options there 3 of those options will
change the units that you measure
degrees in just like you could measure a
distance in like centimeters or inches
or you know meters or whatever
that's there's different units for
measurement of length there are also
different units for measurement of
angles you're in one called gradients
which is a European measure crazy
Europeans you want to change it to
degrees okay which I think for most of
you will be three you see that deg for
degrees the other ones will become
important well in the next couple years
okay so if you haven't already put it
under grace
I think Betty seventies fine okay so
what am I going to do with this
thirty-seven I want it in the second and
fourth quadrants second foot okay so
therefore theta will be in the second
quadrant a hundred and eighty degrees
takeaway 37 okay
that's what theta will become over here
in the second quadrant okay and in the
fourth quadrant it will be 360 take away
that angle okay 360
so if I can coach my numbers well that
should be 143 or 323 so say am i right
yeah okay now unlike before when we were
testing out our on our angles yeah okay
because we approximated if you put in
tan of 143 which I'm gonna do right now
but maybe you can do one of the other
right you're not going to get exactly
negative 0.75 because we approximated
it's not really 37 degrees we're off by
a little margin of error okay but
therefore so should your answer be it'll
be off by a small margin of error I have
minus 0.75 3 5 5 so that's only like
three thousandths of a unit that I'm off
by so I'm pretty close not a bad
approximation so you can see how I
looked I saw a case negative that tells
me what to do with the base angle I've
put it in these quadrants okay let's try
another one let's have a look and see
okay just like before to get this Bay
single the one that I'm gonna work with
here here and here I'm gonna ignore the
sign so that's that - at the front so
I'm gonna go cause inverse of - sorry of
positive zero point three point three
cos inverse on 0.34 - and to the nearest
degree someone got it already
seventy that's convenient okay so
seventy degrees that's what I'm gonna
work with right then I noticed that cos
theta is negative cos is negative so
which quadrants am i interested in is it
called as negative here no nothing's
negative here is it negative here yes it
is because sine is positive and then
down here it's also negative because 10
is positive right if I went around for
completeness sake to this last one cause
it's positive we don't want that we want
it to be negative okay so I've got
second and third quadrants second and
third quadrants so I'm gonna say it's a
hundred eighty take away 70 or 180 + 70
there's the second quadrant angle
there's the third quadrant angle hundred
ten now I should point out you remember
how we made this argument we based it on
the graph right it's like look there are
my solutions that's how I'm going to put
my wedding together if you do this
working quicker though it is you have to
include your quadrants in there you have
to say something about it you can draw
the diagram like we have there if you
want to avoid the diagram um because
your empty diagram you couldn't set this
thing in here this little bit of working
and maybe you want to put this in there
as well as a backup right I can say
since cause is negative then instead of
referring to a diagram which has the
second quadrants on it I just say theta
is second or
quadrant you can see that this sentence
is a replacement or a substitute or just
having the diagram which illustrates
exactly the same point just visually
rather than verbally okay so from here
I'll say that it's in the second third
quadrant and there's my second and third
quadrant or alternatively I say look
there's my diagram off I go